this morning we are kicking off our week
of coverage leading up to International
Women's Day on Friday with a prominent
Democrat exploring a presidential run on
the road to 2020 we are talking to
current and prospective candidates about
important issues that affect the country
senator Kirsten Gillibrand of New York
spent years fighting sexual assault and
harassment in the military and on
college campuses
she is also pushing for a national paid
family and medical leave policy and
legislation to address the country's
high rate of maternal deaths
senator Gillibrand good morning good
morning I know you have announced an
exploratory committee but when will you
let us know if you're officially running
for president now's a good time to say
one way or the other
well I'm taking time to travel around
the country to talk to people about
what's on their minds and I realized
that what's happening this country is
devastating I mean President Trump has
created such divisions such darkness
such hate and we need someone who's
gonna restore what's been lost that
moral integrity that leadership in the
world and I'm running because as a mom
of young kids I really think we need a
president that will fight for other
people's children their communities
their families in the same way you would
fight for your own do you expect to
actually run against Donald Trump if you
become the nominee or do you think he'll
be impeached by the Democratic Party
before then I expect to run against
Donald Trump but I think what we need
right now is the Moller investigation to
be completed to have the report to have
the report made public we have hearings
in the House of Representatives that
will create transparency and
accountability on issues of collusion on
if issues of obstruction on issues of
fraud and election fraud those are the
types of issues that the American people
want clarity on and would you vote for
impeachment of the president well that's
an issue for the house to decide and so
after they complete their investigations
and we heard from several of the
committee chairmen they will decide
whether what the facts are and reveal it
to us and then if they do do impeachment
proceedings then it comes to the Senate
and then you are in charge of basically
holding a trial do you think you have
the support of your own party though yet
senator because it's still the talk of
dinner party conversations about Senator
Gillibrand that she flips and she flops
that she betrayed the Clintons that she
seems to go with whatever the wind is
blowing I know you've heard that how do
you feel about that and how do you
address it well it's certainly not my
record it's not
I am it's true that my first election
was a two-to-one Republican district in
upstate New York and I was able to run
that campaign on getting out of Iraq and
medicare-for-all but still won a
two-to-one Republican district and won a
reelection by a twenty four point margin
then becoming senator of New York I've
been able to bring the state together
the red purple and blue areas with the
highest vote threshold in the history of
the state at 72 percent higher than
anyone who's ever run statewide
including presidential candidates and so
the truth is I am the best candidate to
run against president Trump because I
can bring this country back together I
can not only inspire the base on
progressive issues that I'm running on
like actually passing a green new deal
Medicare for all health care is a right
not a privilege but also being able to
reach out to those red and purple voters
to be heard and to have them come to the
table and be represented let me ask you
this question those your senator the
environment that you would like to have
all those need to happen the green New
Deal Medicare for all paid family leave
you're in the Senate you know what it's
like is there any chance in the world
that such things are going to pass you
talk about bringing people together
Barack Obama talked about that george w
bush talked about that and the country's
only gotten more partisan why are you
gonna be successful where people have
failed miserably on that in fact I'm
already successful I've passed the 9/11
health bill unanimously twice I'm gonna
pass it unanimously again because I have
co-sponsors like Cory Gardner a
Republican you have Tom cotton
sponsoring it this third bill this last
Congress with the Republican House
Senate and president I passed 18 bills
to do that John you have to find common
ground you have to be able to reach
across the aisle listen find out where
you agree and build from there
and sometimes it's small issues like you
know more money for rural broadband but
sometimes it's big issues like repealing
Don't Ask Don't Tell a civil rights
issue which I got done and so what you
need is someone who understands where
their constituents lies so you can find
the common ground bring them together
and actually get legislations passed so
briefly you think there's coming around
on a green new deal and medical you
think you can get Republican votes for
that yes the largest modern Republican
can I tell you why because I believe it
so the green New Deal is three things
these are not new idea
it is infrastructure which is widely
bipartisan more money for mass transit
more money for electric grids more money
for rural water supplies roads bridges
everything the second piece of the green
new deal is jobs it's all about training
people to do wind solar geothermal hydro
power biofuels and we do that in New
York we have amazing SUNY schools where
98% of the graduates have three or more
job offers and all they teach is green
energy LED certified building materials
it works and the third part of the green
New Deal is clean air and clean water
and I can't think of a more universal
issue when you go to upstate New York
they have pollution because of pfoa and
PTFE the same things chew in in New
Hampshire you go to a place like Iowa
they have nitrates in their water
because of farming no matter where you
go you go to Michigan they have horrible
pollution in their water it doesn't
matter if it's an inner city or a rural
area it's something that binds us and
and being a mother back to the whole
point of this week we're in its the
thing that we all have in common we love
our children we don't want our children
to be poisoned by the water they drink
or the air that they breathe
well basically brief conversation this
morning I'm confused about what you're
waiting for to officially announce it
sounds like you laid out a pretty good
plan right here's the website is being
built yes yes it's all coming it's all
coming down yes and I know it's soon
enough I know this won't be our last
conversation I do believe because we
need someone that's gonna heal this
country we need someone who's gonna
listen and and empathize and want to
solve the problems your family's facing
no matter where you live red purple or
blue and I'm the only person running
who's actually done that over and over
and over again in a diverse state like
New York senator thank you so much yeah
okay great to have you on set Kaneda
yeah will continues yeah to be continued